York's pretty awesome but it's sort of
stagnant right now as much as I love
Tokyo and I want to haven't been back
there a lot of eat or in Japan all you
can really get is Japanese food same
thing goes in Italy same thing goes in
France like that's why people say that
is a culinary capital of the world and
that's not an it's not exaggerated it's
because you can really get anything you
want here such a hodgepodge of cultures
and ethnicity that and it's just a
subway stop away from eating Russian
food or or Ethiopian food or stuff like
that and ethnic food is good but it
could be better
I think ethnic food in LA is tremendous
but Mike of all the places I got I think
New York's got some of the best food
around
for sure you know you can get it that's
the thing it's a bagel and for lunch you
can get sushi and then for dinner you
can go get Chinese food you can't do
that anywhere else in the world
got enough time for this
I think there's there's many reasons why
New York stuff to open up a restaurant
probably the most difficult is rising
rents it's completely the real-estate is
increasing so it's not forgiving to
cooks that want to open up restaurants
they are now moving to other cities or
outer boroughs and if you move to the
outer boroughs you're not going to get
the attention you need there's more and
more restaurants so there's less labor
or less talent the city is becoming
incredibly sort of notorious for
cracking down on regulations with the
Health Department Department of
Environmental Protection Agency all
sorts of stuff whether it was a rat
debacle like they're doing a great job
but it's hard enough to open up a
restaurant and be successful but there's
so many roadblocks that prevent you from
sort of maintaining that success and it
would be easier somewhere else outside
of New York but it's just hard hey you
know once you get your doors open just
to be you know alive for a year and then
after that cash trends change cooks
leave it's hard
it's wonderful at least for us the
restaurant we've been again incredibly
lucky for whatever reason foodies or
that word or people that enjoy food like
our restaurant a lot or hate it you know
we're very beloved and very hated
there's nothing really in between and
they really helped to support our
restaurant and I guess by getting and I
don't know what there is to get but they
seem to enjoy our food so we wouldn't be
around without them
you know there's
obviously been a lot of time for Las
Vegas but if that happens it happens
because of the fact it's so difficult to
operate in New York it would be
interesting to see what would happen in
Las Vegas where we wouldn't necessarily
have a tight budget that we work on the
government officials want you to do well
in terms of they're not going to hassle
you to get a hard bar or hard liquor
license you're not going to get noise
complaints you know you have built-in
clientele and they're not as fickle as
as some Las Vegas always officer they
always say because it's money money
money but for us it's we're always stuck
in like these crazy small weird
locations and to have to start fresh in
the new building would be really amazing
and I don't know I don't know like we'd
like to go to other cities as well more
importantly not for me but like for a
lot of the guys like we'd love to look
at Austin Texas you know because for
whatever reason Texas produces a lot of
cooks and they're all in New York City
and like half my guys a lot of the chefs
a lot of the sous chefs and my partner
business partner and chef coach whatever
keep walking Barca eat he's from Austin
and you know God I'm I thinking about a
lot of people from Austin Texas and it
would be nice nice for them they all
want to go back to Texas too so you know
if we're going to open up stuff it's
going to be to provide opportunities for
for guys that have helped
you